yes
10 seconds guys
funny
[Applause]
is
[Music]
so listen i'm sure um we're all aware
it's obviously a very very surreal day
for uh for joe and jess so i'm gonna ask
you a few questions uh about 20 minutes
or so and then we'll open up to you guys
right so
first things first i think
congratulations um
it must be the weirdest possible time
for you yeah
the range of emotions going through your
head right now um but let's just go back
to vast tax um
tell me how this even came about okay so
um
it all started on tuesday that was
working away it was about four o'clock
and i thought i'd probably get a five
ticket because i saw the jackpot and you
better do you buy tickets i do i
normally buy them when you know this is
a good amount so when there's a lot of
money i i'll put it on i use the app and
have a quick check you know a couple of
times a week and then i'll put it on but
generally my
luck is pretty terrible
i've been sticking with it for years but
never
so yeah i did that didn't actually it's
funny because normally i'm more aware of
it but i didn't actually think anymore
that was really busy trying to get
everything done for work
um called it a day went you know carried
on with a normal life went to bed and
then at 5 15 the die normally go feed
the dogs do some jobs around the house
went back to bed and
half half an hour and just checked my
emails my other bits and pieces
and the weather was a normal one for me
and then um so i i checked my emails and
i had an email saying that i'd won a
prize and i took it as the usual lucky
dip type thing and i opened up the app
logged in
and then i looked at the amount
and i put the phone down
and i picked the phone up again and i
looked
i actually started counting the digits
and at that point i thought yeah yeah
it was
amazing but also i'm surreal it didn't
feel of course so i put the phone down
and jess hadn't had a great night's
sleep so i thought i'll wake her up
don't wake her up what do i do so i just
sat there for a minute
trying to take it all in and i thought
i'll give her because it's only 20
minutes i've given the extra 20 minutes
till her alarm goes off
and i um started because normally in
life
we've been trying to move house for
quite a while and other bits including
not being a huge amount of time in the
house we're in now so
you go on the right move and you set
your limits on what you you can't you
hoard and then in the past everything
we've kind of wanted is far beyond what
we could afford so i thought i don't
need to filter i can actually
look at anything
away to myself thinking this is
ridiculous yeah and i still didn't
really believe it but it was fun you
know it was like um yeah
let's make believe at that point yeah it
was yeah and then so then you wake jess
up she's got some water
okay let me wait until my alarm went off
and then normal husband and wife grumpy
morning just let me turn the alarm off
first
ten minutes yeah and he was like i've
got a secret to tell you i've got a
secret to tell you
and then he told me i was like don't be
stupid is that the natural reaction
right yeah he's like
i really think we have i was like oh joe
let me have a look at it thinking you
know it's the morning he just
didn't have my glasses on he's got it
wrong yeah yeah and then i was trying to
do it on my phone but i couldn't get it
to work or something i was like
and then we just kind of thought this is
a fun game to play like it's obviously
wrong there's something wrong with the
app but hey let's go with it and let's
enjoy this moment of thinking we've won
the lottery because it's not real
we said
we'll call them at eight o'clock when it
comes on and check it out
and then i was like right i'll go make
coffee yeah and get on with the day kind
of thing yeah you just thought you know
there's something normally here
so yeah and then at that point eight
o'clock if it was without a phone and
see and then it couldn't you couldn't
make it i had a really terrible phone
signal we're walking all over the house
the lady at the other end was speaking
to me i kept i had to keep repeating all
the information going through like
security checks and i'm thinking this
this
and eventually wait's one of those names
[Applause]
in different ways yeah yeah and uh
we ended up in one of our kids room next
to the window like trying to get signal
and then
all of a sudden the lady was so sweet
wasn't she she was quiet on me and said
i'm gonna put you on hold and then
come back to us and confirmed it i still
didn't believe it at that point she was
so sweet she said joe was like i think i
think we've won the lottery and she was
like oh okay telling us all so how much
do you think you won and he was like no
i think we won
and um so then we went from there so
then she was like and then she said put
us on a hold and she came back on and
she went you definitely have one it was
really sweet and excited yeah so when
that when you put the phone down from
that do you then
what happens then you have a moment to
yourselves i mean obviously it's still
sinking in now yeah
you've still got the balance of nine
pounds eighty which i love and then
underneath you've got you've one then
telling you that you click in when you
want you get all kinds of money that
comes out and it's assumption it's quite
hard to quantify that but yeah yes yeah
it is and then so yeah we worked we
thought we'll wait for the next phone
call and i just
we just
yeah and i went to work i was on my way
to work and i said to joe i rang him and
i said because i work with my mum and my
sister and i was like
we're just not the family that could lie
to one another just you know we're
really close family and i couldn't have
gone to work and not told them something
so i rang joe and i was like joe i'm
gonna have to tell my mum something i
can't lie to her and he was like it's
fine just please don't tell her how much
or get her excited or just had don't
tell anyone just say we wanted to know
we know this is yeah yeah so then
i called her and said oh are you on your
way into work mom and she's like yes and
i said i'll meet you in the car park and
she said to me afterwards she was like
so weird you never meet me quite
straight to say to your mother
so then
i met her in the car park
and i was like i said i've got something
to tell you a secret to telling you but
you have to promise not to tell anybody
she was like okay she said and then she
was like are you pregnant i was like
i said actually what i said was it's
better than being foreign
so so um
i said i think we've won the lottery
and she was like
the euro millions
and i was like
well joe said i i shouldn't talk about
it i don't want to get you
have you won the euro minutes and she
knew all about it exactly how much it
was down for the paper down to the
end and i was like i couldn't hold
anything but i was like i don't know
we're waiting for a call but i think she
just literally screamed in the car park
burst into tears because
even though it's wonderful and exciting
it's also a massive relief for everybody
that's been struggling with all their
bills and all their things for all this
time like we're like every normal family
that has to have that thing so it's just
a huge relief
so let's go into this so tell us a
little bit about yourselves uh what you
do for a living and and your life
so okay so i work for communications for
me and basically obviously like most
people from lockdown i just sat at home
log on 8 30 or 8 in the morning and sit
there 12
six seven six thirty at night and then
just chug away at the keyboard so uh my
life is generally that during the week
and then
weekends aren't it pretty much revolves
around diy and i'm just trying to have
kids
trying to get stuff done because the
house we live in needs loads of work
today and that was basically what we
were doing every weekend i was just
saying to to
i guess we need a bigger fridge because
the list of things i've got just carries
on going down and down and down i can't
get it
in one space it's that big so yeah it's
it's you know it is the things you do in
life you know to get what you're trying
to where you're trying to get to but
yeah it's been pretty hectic so you
changed get up pretty much just chase
your tail yeah yeah yeah 5 15 i get up
and then
yeah so i um
have a
hair salon with my sister and my mum
so i run the business side of that
and
i
have we have a kids so my kids go to
school like primary school and then i
work four days a week and
we have too many animals yeah too many
hands-on that we look after so yeah
we've got geckos
yeah yeah we've got two guests
we have courses
yeah chickens and dogs yeah i mean
yeah we just want to create that kind of
lifestyle for our children we're right
at the bottom because we've you know
pushed everything to
to get this house that we can have our
ponies at home
and um that's been our dream we thought
we'd hit the biggest dream that we could
ever have done i mean in the house we
have so much work to do i was telling
them before like we have a bucket in our
hallway that collects the rain every
time it rains you know you you're
working hard and you've got you
stayed in your life where you you know
you've got your children
and but you're working hand to mouth to
yeah we've we've like
we've got we've saved to do some
building to the house but that's what we
have we're waiting until it's not as
expensive as it is right now because
yeah things but
yeah we're not i'm not saying that um
it's horrendous no we you know we love
our life yeah this is what we've chosen
we absolutely love it yeah and that's
why we're where we are i think when i
met you in a room next door um guys the
first thing that uh that thankfully uh
came to me was this you've both got this
incredible amount of humility about
yourselves and you were aware that the
world is we're in a very tough place at
the moment across the crisis inflation
going up
those things you know
you're aware of those things and and and
how lucky this is yeah i mean especially
you know the way of the world is is
crazy and it's affected our lives and
this couldn't i mean
you couldn't it's not just us before
this were you feeling that before before
it's just amazing that we can what we
can do for our friends and our family
and yeah absolutely so i guess that sex
question is is
why did you decide to um to come
publicly so um because
obviously we want it's not really for us
we want to share this
with our friends and our families loads
of people just really helped us and got
us through a lot and
we want to be able to pass that back but
he can't
this is a secret you've got to keep it
i don't want to
yeah so and you know this is an amazing
thing that's happened to us and this
means it's an amazing thing that's
happened to our family and we want to
share that with them we love them and
that's our main aim to be able to so
it's not about doing this this is our
hardest part
it's about um you know being able to be
open with the people we love and being
able to share amazing adventures with
people
and time as you said
if you ask people to be complicit
um and not say anything
and obviously you want to help your
whole family so that burden that comes
that's quite a lot yeah yeah and you
can't you just couldn't do it we
couldn't lie like that so even the
children you wouldn't want to lie to
your children but then you know they're
excited they're going to go off and tell
their friends and you know we just need
to be open about this and then
find what we're going to do it's also
new we don't know where we're heading
yeah but i think if we want to get back
as quickly as we can to our normal life
obviously it's a whole different version
of a normal life and we get that and we
know how privileged we are and we are so
so grateful
but
we want to be able to share this we want
to be able to have the time to have fun
with our family yeah i mean i guess
because it's so much money so you know
184 million pounds but it was yours one
would say 269 800
but um you know is it too much money for
one person i guess i have to ask that
question we see this as our family
within this yeah
like it is in us it's it's our family
and our friends and all of those kind of
things we're family in places over the
world that we haven't seen for years and
years and we can't wait to either go to
them or bring them to us it's about
time with the people we love
instead of chasing our tale every minute
of the day just to be able to live that
dream yeah yeah i think just for
weekends with the weekends away with the
children and doing things that you know
that building those memories for them
all while you can yeah and this you know
if we look after and look after the
people we love this will look after
generations hopefully yeah and other
people around us and you know that's
that's our hope that we can
you know love all the people that we
love joe just interesting we were
talking earlier you said that
at the moment because you are chasing
your towel you know you finish work and
then
you know the weekends you'll end up you
know you're doing a house you're not
really spending that quality time with
your kids yeah the primary school age
yeah i know that's it's the
you know one of the things in life you
have a balance but
obviously i can change that now and
concentrate more on what i can do and
then what we can do yeah we can't wait
like yeah just having a holiday that
isn't in the tent it's gonna be a matter
i can't wait for that they love doing
simple things with us like they love us
going on bike rides they love us doing
the simple they're not black
those simple things aren't going to go
away yeah it goes oh my gosh no but
actually
yeah same yeah
we can't wait to do those things yep
yeah yeah and well
let's open it up shall we uh
so if you can i know there's a couple of
roving mics thank you
say uh you so
where you're from
hello my name is lisa i'm from sky news
and i just wanted to ask you a quick
question if that's okay and joe to you
are you worried about your heating bills
still and filling up your car and uh
yeah that has changed quite a bit and
and i was thinking about this the other
day that there's a lot of things that
you know a lot of people are struggling
with that you know that has changed
because
you know we built we just bought we had
the house we moved into you base
everything on how much money you've got
and and on all of those
that you know all those costs are
totally changed now so that this is this
is huge for us you know but yeah i did
put the immersion eating on the other
day and heated up the hot water so
that's fine we're in the past you know
these are sort of things you just didn't
you don't do so
yeah it's huge jess do you worry about
going public
i i've been really worried about going
public yeah just because
i want to protect the people i love
i want to make sure that they're all
okay
and
yeah it isn't really something that i
i've dreamed of doing absolutely but i
feel this is the way that we can be
honest to them all
we can enjoy it with them all and it's
going to allow us to give them loads to
them
thank you
hi both natasha from the bbc um just
wanted to ask on that subject of on that
subject of going public are you worried
about scammers people coming forward who
might want to take your money from you
is that one of the concerns around going
publicly i haven't even i haven't even
thought of anything like that to be
honest we're a week in
we're like so overwhelmed by other stuff
i i just haven't even got to consider
that if i'm honest
with all the positives i mean that's the
main thing of this is there's a lot of
positives so yeah
hi brother harris five news uh do you
both feel that you have a responsibility
now with the sheer amount of money that
you've won given that we're in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
um i don't okay
this is also new to us that there's a
lot of things we've got after this we've
got to go away we've been so busy this
week just trying to you know with work
and everything else just trying to get
everyone else in a good place that
because obviously we knew
we couldn't but you know i think those
people are in the same boat as us so
absolutely we
we um get where they are but we just got
to get our head around this yeah and
think things through and move on from
there i think
hello there matt drake good morning
britain
two questions first of all were you
using the same numbers and if so is
there any significance of those numbers
more importantly
who's going to play you in the film
so um i always go with the lucky dip
because i just think that's easier you
just buy a lucky dip on either the
lottery or the national lottery
depending on which one looks like it you
know it's got a lot there's a lot of
money there and that yeah that's it my
um my family my dad played the lottery
all of our when we were growing up and
he played the same numbers every single
week um he died about seven years ago
and kind of joe took on the baton as the
one who did the lottery for our family
so he started off using those numbers
but he'd forget them or get them wrong
or something so we then went to lucky
dip so that it was luck but yeah it's
unbelievable because that's what my dad
dreamed of all his life and tried used
to say to us frequently imagine if you
won the lottery think about if you win
the lottery and um
yeah it's just crazy
but who's going to play you in the film
i mean yeah they say so now that you
know
that's another
things that crossed my mind there's a
whole list of things
joe you've got some stanley teaching
vibes
you've talked a lot about spending time
with family
but is there one thing you've always
dreamed of buying
um
we're not really those materialistic
people you saw our house you would know
that you know but i don't i think
i'll probably buy a new car i'm sure or
something like that but we haven't got a
huge we'd love to go on a family holiday
more experience yeah we have we'd love
to we had to go buy suitcases to come
here because we don't go on holiday we
never go on holiday um so our kids would
just
die to go to the sun and do that kind of
thing so i'd love to go and do that yeah
that's the main thing that they've
talked about it's holidays
so uh yes my our youngest constantly has
always wanted to go to hawaii i think
youtube's to blame for that
we have no idea why but they're obsessed
with the way the other one wants to go
to like a texas ranch uh trail thing
where you write courses across uh
steve nibs from the bbc as well um huge
congratulations first of all from the
local bbc you've talked about helping
family and friends that's almost a
no-brainer this is such a huge amount of
money are there any causes close to your
heart that you're going to try and do
something philanthropic with the money
help charities or causes that that you
work that he's got no i think that's an
area we will get to but we're one
weekend
it's blown our mind just getting to this
point and um
you know we're we're not there yet but
we're going to definitely take some
advice and talk to you about go from
there because you know it's yeah it's
just the first moment it's real yeah
it's very real yeah so up until this
point i still keep thinking i'm gonna
like fall out of bed and and it's all
gonna be yeah a dream my mum
yeah exactly right yeah
my mom keeps texting me saying are we
alive
i'm like well we're all not alive if
we're not alive so it's okay we're
together in that situation
hi yeah congratulations again both um
i'm james i'm from bower media we have
commercial radio stations around the uk
um two things for me if i can firstly
you've talked a lot as steve pointed out
about wanting to help family
i wonder you know the story with this
sort of thing is always that you guys
have become multi-millionaires but i
wonder if you plan on
making family members millionaires as
well and are you
comfortable saying you know
is there a number of people do you want
to make millionaires after that
give them a list yeah yeah so it's
another thing that i think we just got i
think through you know you think about
winning a lottery and you know you have
this idea but when it actually happens
my brain's been blank for seven days
i've struggled to finish off anything at
work struggle's just finished his
sentences
we definitely want to look after our
family it will be about all of us
together so we feel like our family won
the lottery not only our immediate
family our extended family and we can't
wait to share it with them so absolutely
we haven't got as far as we haven't got
a plan we haven't got a plan no
i think what's interesting like talking
to you guys uh next door you're such
busy people that that you will still
have per you'll find purpose off the
back of this that's quite important
will you have the leaky roof repaired
now yeah this is hot definitely and it's
not going to be me up there which is
amazing so yeah
will you stay there or will you will he
move we don't know at the moment yeah i
mean we've been there two months so
we're not in love with our house yet we
just moved in
um so we it we i mean we are alone but
yeah if anything we don't know we won't
need to be there if we have building
work done we've got the ability now to
move away and not be covered in dust
which is what we've got at the moment
everything's covered in dust so yeah
um
you go in
cycles of how you feel about this
generally quite positive but you know
there's a lot going on because it
doesn't really still feel real i i don't
really know
i think we weren't scared right at the
beginning yeah but the more you get to
understand it the more scary it is
but we're just going to take the best
advice that we can yeah definitely
because like questions today the things
that we don't even think about yet yeah
there's a lot of things that we haven't
considered and we've been so busy this
week has been trying to tie everything
up with work and family and friends we
really haven't had time to think about
it yeah so we're looking forward to that
bit
of the dreaming bit yeah they were quite
scared ten minutes before they came out
here
hi uh charlotte from southwest news
service uh jess you said that you were
worried about going public what is it
that changed your mind what why have you
made the decision um i i i'd say we just
thought we're normal people just the
same as everybody else like there's no
news story or like i feel like i'm you
know i'm just we're just the luckiest
people ever
so um
i just didn't know that we would need to
i didn't think it was something we'd
have to do
and then the more i thought about it i
was like and the more we felt the burden
on our family from one week of telling
some people were like we could never do
this to them and there's so many special
people to us and we want to enjoy that
and let them be excited because they're
so excited for us and for them and the
future of our children really i guess
with that amount of money as well
i guess it's a case unless you do
nothing you have to tell someone right
and as soon as you tell someone then
you're asking them to take on that bird
yeah we just couldn't do it anymore yeah
yeah
i was just wondering are you um off work
at the moment both of you and when do
you plan to return
so i've been working up until yesterday
i handed over what i had at work
yesterday afternoon
um i wanted to get as much done as i
could so i didn't want to leave the guy
to work with
you know in trouble um
in some ways that helps as well with
this because you've got something to
take your mind away from the situation
but but yeah so i've got a few days off
i'm gonna see how it how it goes um i
think in some ways a bit of a normal
life from time to time probably will
help so yeah we'll say my side yeah i'm
not off work i have a team that rely on
me i've been still paying my wages this
morning and doing all those sorts of
things so
um i don't know what i'll do in a week
or two i'm definitely going to take some
time but i have an amazing team
that will that have just worked so hard
through the last month so
i will take some time to work out what
i'm going to do
yeah
um oh sorry
hi i'm freya karim from the times i'm
still on the subject of work are you
planning to stay in work and if you are
why
um i don't think we are at the moment i
think we will take some time i don't
know about my salon as part of my family
business i think um i'm gonna take some
time with that and what we're going to
do and hopefully it's
they they will they will wait they have
time and can look after it for me i'm
really proud of them but i think i'm
going to oh yeah i'm leaving work i just
don't want to you know i was just trying
i think we're going to have a full-time
job just managing all of this for quite
some time and so um
joey's really conscientious in his work
and we're constantly like dad [ __ ] the
kids are like can't you leave that yeah
he's like no just give me five more
minutes to finish what i'm doing so he
just wouldn't cope with letting people
down or all of these kind of things so
yeah he has handed us an extent
hi there phil barnett from the press
association um to what degree or to what
extent of your circle have you told
people and how many people are going to
be spitting the coffee out while they're
watching this
it's really hard because obviously when
as soon as you tell people before today
then you know they're with their friends
and family and they're a situation where
we've said please don't tell anyone but
they want to jump up and down and run
around screaming so so we started with
just telling close back our brothers and
sisters and our mum and that went until
literally yesterday
and then
we've told our close friends now that we
wanted to tell personally so yeah we've
told a few of them
as many as we had time to yeah it isn't
it wasn't a huge amount because
it's people people because of the whole
thing there's probably other people that
we've missed the whole thing so it's
gone so quickly and it just feels like a
roller coaster to a certain extent so
yeah hopefully after today we can sit
down and take some time with the kids
and just take it easy and think about
this a bit more
how's your mum chess she alright she's
relieved with of her own situation and
she's
unbelievably excited for us she want to
tell like yeah she's yeah yeah she does
i'm well i mean she's not excited to
tell her that she's she's just yes so
happy for us happy for our family that
we can look after them
um the normal worries that she would
have and um yeah we're happy that i know
that i can look after her forever
yeah
hi congratulations on your win joe black
from bbc news um jess you've talked
about your late father and how he played
the lottery what would he say about your
significant win and obviously you no
longer need to play the lottery but do
you think you'll carry on that tradition
because obviously your father played
every week um so
he would absolutely love this not the
limelight but the dreaming and the
possibilities that we'll have for the
people we love and that's he's all about
a community and he used to tell us he'd
have his family in a village
that would all live and separate like he
loved that idea of he was so proud of
his children and his grandchildren so
he would love this and the the fact that
um we can share it would just absolutely
top a day
i think someone else's turn yeah it's
someone else's turn to have the luck we
pass that on imagine if they won again
no don't be silly
we've taken the long time we're not
young
we're not young we've done it for a long
time
good morning uh james from the sun
firstly congratulations to both of you
must be absolutely fantastic my two
questions obviously
you've spoken about what you might be
doing with money but just between
the two of you after you initially found
out in that news registered what did you
do to to celebrate and my second
question is obviously you know that
there have been other big winners in the
national lottery over the past are you
going to reach out to them maybe so for
some advice on how to approach this
journey that you're about to embark on
yes so we've had a family meal haven't
we we went and had a family meal so that
we could just share it with our family
by ourselves we haven't really done
anything
i'll tell you the truth we bought
bedroom furniture we've been living in
packing cases in our bedroom because we
couldn't have
furniture so i was like do you know what
i'm going to go and buy us furniture so
we bought chest of drawers in a wardrobe
um but
other than that for us we haven't done a
gift
or any you know we've had a celebration
with our family yeah and and as far as
the advice goes i think that we need as
much as possible yeah we want as much
help as we can
sorry just one very quick last one from
me um
clearly think events like this make this
very real and having the people on the
phone tell you you've definitely won and
all that makes it very real but i wonder
have you actually had the money go into
your bank account yet because that's
when it really becomes
finalized
you stole the comedy check yeah yeah
yeah
i'm off down to lawyers with that
to be honest we haven't seen a bank
account with that money in no
we don't yeah we haven't seen that yet
so yeah no we're not in that position
where we've opened our app and gone oh
you know
good luck
thank you thank you that's so lovely
thanks chef thank you
okay
[Music]